we got to talk about this first we got
to clear the air now the audience won't
know what I'm talking about right but
there might be some Conan people out
there that know last year you were
booked to be on this show I was and you
were supposed to be here and we said
Zachary Levi is coming and you were
gonna fly in from New York and you were
booked on like I don't know a Thursday
or something and that morning I come
into work and around noon they say he
missed his flight he slept late and he's
not gonna be here now when you hear that
like a Gary Busey did that you're not
shocked right you think yeah those had
an 80% chance of happening but Zachary
Levi is known as a guy that always shows
up you're a pro you're a nice guy thank
you so I could only assume that you had
a horrible drug problem and I've dealt
with it and this is part of your therapy
therapy my penance I I worked late that
night I I'm not gonna lie had a couple
of beers I had a couple of beers but if
anybody here has an iPhone I don't know
if you know this if your alarm goes off
for long enough and you happen to not
hear it it will go off by itself it will
literally turn itself off there's no
more noise I didn't know that I always
hear it and turn it off immediately
because your report is why to meet my
yes that's what I do yes and you don't
have a meth habit so that's also I felt
so I thought you shouldn't feel bad we
we got through it we actually had some
fun with it at the time but I'm just
glad to hear you're okay
I'm okay I saw your iPhone so I'm gonna
get so much crap on an Apple no no no no
not at all you'll never get a free one
again
you